That's an old painting by,
I think it's Hieronymus Bosch,
if I remember correctly.
I really liked that because it's,
it's reminiscent of the
near death experiences that
you hear people describing.
They're quite common as well.
And,
and uh,
I had it very weird experience once.
I don't think I've told you this story.
I was,
I was assessing someone who had gone
through a car windshield and he was very
depressed.
It had happened a long time before,
but he was very depressed
and the insurance company
was basically accusing him
of a malingering cause he'd been
depressed for so long and you know,
he'd sort of healed up and everything.
But if your left hemisphere is damaged,
especially the frontal part
of your left hemisphere,
then you can be in a chronic state of
depression because the left hemisphere,
generally speaking,
is responsible for positive emotion.
And so if it isn't there,
then it's like negative emotion for you.
And so I went and assessed
him and I was giving him this,
I think it was called the MMPI,
the Minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory,
which is a kind of a standard,
uh,
path personality test,
half psychopathology test.
And uh,
he was filling it out.
He was a very serious guy,
middle aged guy,
nothing about them was
new agey in the least.
He was like an accountant I think.
I think in fact he was an accountant,
if I remember correctly.
Um,
and there's one question and it said,
my spirit has left my body.
I think that's right.
It's very close.
And he stopped and he asked me what,
well,
he said,
I'm not sure how to answer this.
And so I said,
well,
why?
And he said,
well,
after I went through the car windshield,
I was in a coma for three weeks,
something like that.
And I died.
I think he said he died three times
and he said that he could remember,
he couldn't remember anything during
that period of time and he couldn't
remember the car accident.
That's retrograde amnesia.
It's quite con common with head injuries.
And he said that during
one of those experiences,
and this is all he
remembered from the hospital,
was that he came out of his body and
went down the long tunnel of light.
You've heard these near death experiences
and then saw his family members there
and so other heavenly light and then
realized that it wasn't his time and came
back to his body.
Now what was interesting
about this guy was that,
well first of all,
I didn't ask him about this,
right?
He basically volunteered this story and
it was instigated by this question and,
and he didn't know that
anybody else had any,
he ever had an experience like that.
Cause I asked him if he'd ever heard
anything about like that and he said no.
So that was interesting.
But what really was interesting is
how the hell did he remember that?
Right?
Because he had amnesia during
that entire period of time.
He was in a bloody coma.
It's like he didn't remember anything.
He remembered that.
And so,
well those experiences are
more common than you think.
And then there's,
you know,
there's a painting of one,
which is quite interesting,
and that's like a tunnel to heaven.
It's the same basic idea.
It's a little bit more
suffering going on in this one,
I think.
But that's pretty much
typical of Hieronymus Bosch.
I mean,
I don't know what was up with that guy,
but he was,
he was one strange character.